I I don't want to turn this into the
gambling episode oh no dude people want
to see evolve our content uh news flash
people we've done everything there is to
do on this website reactive
videos you're doing that like a thousand
times you make music we've done that
already what's next filming from our
iPhones of us gambling at slot machines
and the content is unedited it's hours
long and it's just this yo
we're here
what's up so 45 minutes ago we hit a
stupendous win stupendous win kind of
still riding that energy I'm gonna go
walk in a circle yep because that seems
to work yep around the Cinderella
machine I'm gonna go do a figure eight
around that and I'm gonna pull my pants
down and rub my butt on the
on the rich little piggies machine you
know just to feel like a pig's ass and
then we're gonna light it up and then
just
all right
seemed to like when I did this before
yeah